we Carlos Carlos we're going on his
Carlos
oh yeah we're in my favorite save room
well it's not really my favorite it's
just the one I did spend a lot of time
in so what I am liking about being back
here is how I'm getting to see kind of
the static character I wouldn't really
say I guess static NPCs like the dead
people and we're getting to see how they
died oh yeah we're good I think
so what's the plan Stan for my doing
not quite remember
got some quarreling zombies at least mr.
X isn't here
it's always nice with me like this way
or up that way this uh noise up that way
I remember but I'm gonna go in this way
hello there was always a zombie here
before they changed that now and now
she's around here there's a reason here
well that is different
unless she jumps out the shower I'm
freaking myself out now I'm scared okay
she's not here
whoa oh oh my god and where'd the one
who blows up this wall that's gonna call
see you see you seemed like how the
environment got formed ready for when we
played it back in the days of Resident
Evil 2 this is pretty cool yes we'll be
doing this lately yes yeah but
I can't see ourselves in the mirror I
guess they only put reflection in a very
beginning in Jill's room damn it it's
not CAF is it no that was me that was
the last one no something is cap I'm
just going to try cap is it kid
oh thank you is that ready yet the only
locker I can anything else down here for
me
[ __ ] CJ why is it blocked
I can hear an ominous whirring noise
la ICU
I've shank you a [ __ ] shank you me
[ __ ] shank you oh you don't mind I
don't like that nah yeah oh god I can't
see there's a pillar in the way I wish
you could just shake them rather down
just like get the knife and put it
through the head don't start whacking
his legs oh gotta keep slowly filling oh
I know I see you I see you should i
shanked this one too
what I keep missing too well I don't
think he's getting back up okay cool
oh it's all blocked I felt like you
should have said that
blocking line up here not down there
because this is where we were
intentionally going was he supposed to
say it down that I felt like you should
have said up here
oh wow
cap
B no I've got to space it space it
dammit I didn't why space on the last
one I just clicked okay let's try a cap
again in the last one don't get back up
buddy
just find something to blow that up
oh I missed something No - a friend
Hector if you're reading this I'm
already dead if you hear any noises
coming from the locker don't open it
why we open the locker why are we open
the knot what while you were on patrol I
focused on finding a way to get to the
other side I realized that explosives
might be our best bet I managed to break
up a pretty good bomb but we don't have
any batteries for the detonator I'm
pretty sure I sent one to the safety
deposit room during in taped last week
we need that battery if we're going to
knock down this wall so I headed
upstairs to find you since I know you
have the safety deposit room key toxic
so that's the key that I've got safety
deposit room as soon as I left the
shower room I was attacked
abduct one of them bit me I washed the
room as best as like her but I feel
worse and worse I hope I don't need to
spell out why you must not open that
locker oh so that's where she is she's
in the locker like excited for this open
yeah
your buddy Wes PS don't worry about that
600 I lent you think of it as a gift
towards your upcoming move that's a very
very nice of him
wait now I can open this locker it's
this locker that it's in not this one
because I couldn't open that locker
before I swear I couldn't open it before
cap
she's in this one should we open it what
do you guys think I mean yeah they leave
me off see don't we
better not Oh what you're making your
own decisions now I you I thought I was
your master what doesn't you give me the
Compton law that's kind of cool though
that there wasn't from that until you've
read the letter and then there was a
problem and then it wouldn't let me do
where I'm guessing something's gonna
happen later and she's gonna like pop
out of there
oh it's gonna be so freaky not looking
forward to that a moment
doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo
okay so I've got a key to some kind of
room
Muslim map stars hmm oh okay so he was
supposed to say on this floor
fair enough
so can't go anywhere up there ah safety
deposit room first floor oh it's right
by our save room oh I know where it is
this is the gun room this is the item
room okay cool we'll go back stop
I thought I killed you oh my god we'll
put this away for now oh just save a
see-through
why am I scared cuz I thought I killed
him like you always think they're dead
and then you just hear them coming after
you
this one definitely is oh look at that
look at that mess we need to make them
all like that oh no I remember what I
have to do this is why it's hard to play
on the PC because you're supposed to
sneak and like it's hard to sneak on a
PC guys tell me how to sneak on a PC do
I just do this oh my god
I can't do this please don't read
towards me oh god please imagine wants
me Oh God
things I butcher what's me okay please
over towards me okay ah
I'm trying to Smee cuz I know you can't
see if you like run oh it [ __ ] worked
yes I'm too busy being impressive myself
over the liquor how dare you take that
achievement away from me
why I'm so jumpy today I just tank just
give me a moment's peace please [ __ ]
hell I'm gonna have to stop playing just
walk normally it can hear you oh I
thought you had to walk like super
quietly because when you're playing with
a controller you come like proper sneak
oh look at coming to get you
I know what you're doing I'm going that
way I'm gonna make your head split open
and you do not come back up yet wow this
year
oh wait
cut head off
don't get up either of you please
see what we got here now I want to
caution some too bad
no shift is to sprint but yeah I think
you guys are right hopefully I just
walked like this you won't be able to
hear me because if you sprint by a
liquor then ah you are in for some bad
times
okay so 109 for grenade what I'm
guessing y'all we missing keys still
probably yeah so we're missing two or
three we can get the 109
okay so we got grenades 106 we can open
up that one 106 104 106 and also when I
oh the battery okay cool
what else have we got here
mind now
oh we don't need no I know
so generic
okay we can't open the twos we don't
have a two others nothing in here anyway
on the side he grunted I thought I was a
zombie getting back up again
oh hello don't think I didn't see you
there well I didn't but now I did
there's nothing even in here
how do those guns get there Leon and
Claire Oh DCM DCM devil crime eh that'll
help me remember it I don't want to go
back out there that's quite
Oh God don't do this
oh I thought I could open a door like
this
I'm gay
okay I hope you guys are right about the
liquor not wait he's gone I'm not gonna
run there oh it's just you well
hopefully you'll if it's not around here
because I'll be dead else look it's not
here
where the hell did that let me go I mean
I'm grateful but did it did it push you
down the stairs okay
we're going to take this an hour cuz I'm
guessing once we get to that locker up
there that you know I don't store it can
I take it out and put it in here
what am I saying what was the same yeah
I'm guessing once we get to the locker
upstairs that we're gonna get into the
battery because that's really the only
next point of progression that we've got
really isn't it so I've got a lot of
stuff
should I use I don't like using green
herbs until I'm like in the red we'll
just take one of these out I guess
whatever whatever don't stop
overthinking this
ah who is it Lenny if you're having
framerate issues maybe try watching on
twitch I'm YAG my necks on twitch as
well sometimes people say that it runs
about or lunch for it and tweet I still
to this day I have issues thing arse I
always say like what instead of rough so
annoying it took me so long when I was
kid just stop doing that
all right devil cry mate yeah oh oh wait
did I only need one battery oh hell yeah
okay sweet let's go blow up some stuff
then
okay she is going to come out of the
bathroom isn't she
of that locker she's gonna come out of
it
oh he's coming come so I don't have to
be our ID I'll just wait for you
probably shouldn't do that
should I use my curbs nah I'm sure we'll
be fine okay
nice one
Carlos look what you did this hole was
bigger oh my god wait wait I need to
find I have some stuff yeah yeah this is
great
wait join it no no no no no I don't know
hold up guys
put up
oh my god there's so many of you maybe I
should have used my grenade but it feels
like pointless now oh my god
so many of you she is she out with us oh
no I can't go back oh my god
that's quite enjoy shooting I'm taken
over there already no no
it's it actually brings some nice very
satisfying right okay [ __ ] off you shut
your shut so these are old cups but what
about the civilians why were they here
what's their story were you were you
being arrested
oh yeah she probably all right I'm ready
for you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
I got two coffee no I got to cook oh no
I'm fine
oh here this okay I'm finally going I'm
leaving guys
I can't even get past it I think I'm
gonna have to try and do this
I hate fighting them though I thought I
was getting is he gonna move thought was
getting more
oh I always saw if I put my flashlight
on them that they would see me okay
shall I just use my grenade yes please
do DS oh yeah oh my gosh I know but that
one grenades managed to rip off all of
its skin it's quite impactful okay we
made it to the office
doctor barge oh god no how I'm not
trying to read somebody don't worry
we're gonna get you out of there just
tell me where you are I'm trapped in a
goddamn hospital surrounded by every
kind of abomination but just sending
stars they're gonna know what to do
negative RPGs overrun - and figure it
out alright brothers gone crazy they're
killing all the researchers the only one
who knows how to make the vaccine to
stop the zombies so you can either sit
there with your dick in your ass and
send somebody who's capable of getting
me the hell out of here
I like him already
yeah you would
you know what he said we can't turn them
over with compass how did you get here
right that's my house call I'm gonna
check the computer see if I can trace
the docks location
this will take some time look around see
if you can find anything useful okay
being nosy is like my special ability
we probably read this before in our last
playthrough the only survivors are five
members of stars the cause of the
incident was the illegal biographer
morality virus bees and experiments is
it I can't see her can you see her
I don't think any of those look like
jail that's all that's in my thinking
about jail still even in these hard
times
Oh make it
Oh lol oh you guys in here get one of
you out might as well put you in there
too
and then I can combine these guys oh I
need some more hanged um and I
he hung gun ammo in here got
flash-grenade another one
oh I can use that card okay we've got a
lot of assault rifle ammo we have a lot
of that
I think have you found everything yeah
we found thing am I supposed to get back
out hold out I want to knife that box
I never nice the box the year yeah
what's up rail was anyone hurt Jill oh
[ __ ] what Jill Jill what happened
chill come in
see I gotta go do what you got I'll take
care of bar
hmm where am I going now then so was
that all the time that we spend at the
police station well we never knife that
box
okay well back is chill okay oh well
yeah it looks like that
sorry jell-o I like your necklace what
is it it's just oh this is the strip of
metal okay
I thought shows religious for a second
what a beautiful sound well at least we
have all our guns can't remember if this
is everything we left off without
guessing so ok so I'm trying to find a
good range to contact him and then then
I'll cut to the bit that we just saw on
his end what's this mine
good news lipsticks I got some new
weaponry for you that's guaranteed to
put the brass back in you sex Nicole my
rounds
these babies were developed by umbrellas
military R&D and they will light your
fires even harder than that lover you
left back home that tough to find and
tricky to handle but trust me they're
worth it alright let's look at the specs
my rounds a design for standard-issue
grenade launchers don't get cute and try
to load them into anything else by the
walls on the ground and they'll stay
right where you put them the sensor in
the mine will detect approaching enemies
oh this is cool
and detonate when they get within range
so yeah this would have been so good in
that room with the the multiples of
zombies coming out so basically just saw
some in the omni's path and you got
yourself a la mine there's no such thing
as I'm fair when you're taking on those
giant brick so get out there and fight
dirty so we can't help but putting on
stupid accents why don't we have any
shotgun shells this is bad I think I
wasted a lot of my ammunition denied
because I was taking on nemesis a bit
too much it's getting a bit
trigger-happy okay
I need I needs goods whatever I need
good ah [ __ ] pretty perfect
oh yes he's she's fine she's faking it
go back to my Carlos saving knife for
that box but
some be down there anything in this
wheelbarrow
to try our new gun let's try the mine
rounds
will it detonate me too though because
that's an issue wow it's so blue
all right everyone wakey wakey wakey
wakey
you're dead perfect like this gun
nothing in these cells for me no hanging
on my shotgun ammo
oh [ __ ] oh no that wasn't very well
calculated one more whoa whoa l owe you
no absolutely fell for me didn't you
so I killed used to it oh my god okay
KITT falling into me my own nothing
around here ready to get that's not
you're still alive
I can't stay here
escape the crew again are you [ __ ]
kidding me
oh that scared me thanks for following
Sal Jesus Christ oh thank you
dude clock tower st. micheal's clock
tower is a baroque style building which
stands at the heart of Raccoon City it
has become a beloved iconic
nemesis's afternoon you just sit down
and read a pamphlet about the parks our
residents consider it to be emblematic
of the city of the whole st. Michael's
Church erected this tower in 1908 with
the assistance of several palanca pests
it was surgically chewed to the sick
children born in a developing city and
the first floor was used as an
elementary school for many years the
city sought further growth during its
electrification over the course of the
early 20th century and the student body
of st. Michael's Elementary swelled to
over 600 students unfortunately st.
Michael's Elementary was shuttered in
1978 is the building began to show signs
of age of where the clock was
deactivated in strict limitations were
placed on entry to the surrounding
premises years passed with this once
beloved Monument and public plaza on
lockdown but in the 1990s the umbrella
corporation worked in league with Mayor
Michael Warren to renovate and be open
the area this time with proper
preservation efforts in place the cooked
hour was officially reopened in 1993 and
today the sound of its heavy tolling
bells can once again be hair throughout
marcoon City
thank you that's extremely informative
it's nice little bit of information to
help me forget that I'm being hunted
down right now by nemesis
there's more things to pick up where
could they be cool statue
Oh
oh she doesn't even have a nice fine
this
I want ballots picked up
I want ammo [ __ ] out
please go into the water just go into
the water I've had enough of your
shenanigans
wait nobody bad things that means it's
not on fire anymore I think you can swim
Jill Carlos we didn't make it the train
derailed
meanwhile everybody
nikolai gels i think you can swim
I tried brother oh my god [ __ ] damn
right bones are sticking out and stuff
I'm glad I'm not playing oh [ __ ] no I'm
playing okay go
kill
oh nice one
she is that she indestructible how can
she survive him something in his chest
[Laughter]
I'm a big big big big big gun anybody
gun
Oh
what is that noise that keeps happening
I feel like this isn't doing anything I
don't know what to do there the noise
that keeps happening this stuff over
here oh let me pick up the [ __ ]
what I like about you you hold me tight
what is the red do again I can't
remember
Bollywood sauce my however what does
this one do then cuz this one funny
restores my health only a small bit Oh
never wanna let you go now you make me
feel alright submit it tell me all the
things I wanna hear I'm on fire
where am I supposed to [ __ ] I feel like
I feel like there's like a place I'm
supposed to be hitting him I don't know
where I keep on Jill what you doing keep
on running pass here and I hear this
noise is like I wish I could just melee
this [ __ ] do you hear that
what the hell is he doing uh can't stop
him
[ __ ]
I got what I'm very confused
Oh guys freaking Batman
oh my god this is bad
wow I thought oh this is for sure dead
but I wasn't somehow oh my god
what is that noise it's actually annoy
me I fell that's something that I
haven't noticed and it's around here why
is he jumping around I know he's fat and
I've only got one explosive round map
today
oh come on seriously you tell me I just
wear that
turn around you'll Beach Oh God Oh God
wait no that's gonna call him a [ __ ] he
didn't like that I'm sorry
[ __ ] this come on come on how like go
here
oh thank you
but see I've really feel like there's
something that I'm just not getting
about this gameplay loop losing my [ __ ]
gun
by the time I figure it out I am gonna
have like wasted all of my ammunition
so what am I supposed to shoot
all right that should be why is that the
way
that's a lot of [ __ ] around here
actually they even notice Oh No
beginning of it up
wasn't it welcome boy these mines just
casually like oh okay well if I maybe if
I used well I do have more fire for this
one oh my god wait no if you ever use
the mine on the wall okay [ __ ] you sir
right I'm gonna
my god wasted so much ammunition so
destroyed in myself
yes I know by okay
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
is it dead is it head cause of the games
chest a dancer I don't start down
was it due anywhere is it
I thought I put a mine up there
okay come
yeah I am going to kill you
Oh
dars well okay if I die then at least I
know like what I'm doing next time
go go run you little fish
now what the [ __ ] mine realms
this is actually [ __ ] ridiculous
yeah
come on girl
uh-oh I don't have any more mine rounds
left
[ __ ]
no I stupid my rounds
come on
oh my god what the hell
oh [ __ ]
alright don't use your mind round save
them oh yeah I'm probably gonna die
I know
some on flame I'll keep my mind mount
out oh gosh still upon yet
go on then little boy run up your clock
tower
is that what you did I still doing this
okay I know
it's actually so ridiculous
they better give me so much armor after
this because this is not okay
let's see go you know [ __ ] her
then you please dining out blazing it so
many tiny
okay that was actually more annoying
than awesome did that went on for waited
on I don't know if it's cuz I was being
stupid or what but I feel like oh my god
that's y'all like I am going to pay for
that I hope I I've already picked
everything up from here as well and I'm
almost dead well I think I've got green
hair back in uh in my little safe so
there's that at least you're not
actually dead though are you
I doubt it yeah
yeah oh we took his arm off
wait does this mean she's infected I
thought she already was infected though
oh no he got her local is
half-a-day she's been there for half a
day sure
Tyrel do you copy going on Jill's been
infected I I'm taking her to the
hospital
maybe dr. Barton Seaver
yeah but look look what she took down
look through the gates and be like wow
damn girl
oh wait I think nemesis was gone just as
armless there so that's not the end of
that one
why did you
fight it chill
I'm gonna get you the vaccine white it's
like every manly game character sound
the same you just saw this gruff voice
like you never get like I don't know
like a northerner or something like I
don't know like a Liverpudlian or
something no offense am i living finally
I'm funny
well I want different accents right
anyway thank you for the ammo oh yeah
I'm him okay well I listen we have to
worry about our lack of ammunition then
can we take her stuff oh no we need to
give her as a vaccine okay
let's just say we're just gonna steal
all of her stuff from her pockets to
this that's rude anything here
can I combine these peers okay so we
will hang gun but you've got a lot of
these I'll put this away and say that I
have three of them on us why not I can
oh I can get rid of you now bow to store
it instead okay
you are in America in Games's one
explanation yeah but even Americans have
different types of accents you know you
have like you're southerners and like
like all different types of American
accents like why is always just a
generic one
[Music]
I'm happy a healthy family of a happy
family just cute eat while kissing where
I'm on and this is completely new
hey I can't go outside can i no just get
some dramatic wind oh so I came from
maybe know that way am I going
can't get that way I guess the only
other door that I can get but there's
something here apparently I haven't
picked up oh is it
maybe it's behind the deaths
Oh is he it yeah more was still rifle
ammo Susie
nobody expect me to do a lot of done
playing since I no jail I know
that's quite dramatic
if you have a grenade on us
but
through a little bit too high but okay
yeah they definitely expected us to do
love guns
please don't get back up please don't
get back up [ __ ] every shop you know hit
me she bit me
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] fun like out oh
my god
no stay down you [ __ ]
which way do I go that's our friend whoa
okay we need a lockpick
well maybe we come back to swears Jill
then because she's got a lot pick only
we could take it off her body no thank
you
okay so
umbrella corporation staff spring
it's like aspirin but not how do I get
out there then can I
that liked it maybe maybe elsewhere
[Music]
saving the world
he didn't have anything witty to say
every day they bring in more of these
mystery illness patients the sedatives
don't stop their delirium so we have to
put them in straitjackets and move them
to the isolation bring foreign Lizzio
Silesia brain is already bursting at the
scenes the dawn directors ordered us to
admit anyone with symptoms free of
charge but what does he expect us to do
wish them better we don't have a cure
and that's not all that's bothering me
when these patients died they're not
collected by the usual mortuary teams
we've been told it's special handling to
prevent the illness from spreading but
I'm not sure I buy it
Miranda saw some guys wheeling a body
hit the forbidden door during the night
why where what's going on way too close
to home I guess I can't do this then oh
I wonder
okay so if I get a cassette tape of his
voice then maybe I'll let me through
there's no cassette in it yet
dr. barred are you in there I'm here to
rescue open the door
no boys watch round this match
what kind of sci-fi it's only security
is stopping him from getting saved
great
well at least we go a little green HAP's
okay this is not good
open up the door
[Music]
no not mine I hate being stuck behind
doors
boys on the floor he's up and she can
back up all the [ __ ] doors to get out
the way he's breathing to [ __ ] run
around me
[Applause]
[ __ ] you die
oh please okay back up please okay back
up please okay back up please okay back
up with oh yeah did we put that card
away where's that card gone shizer
do we need that card and I feel like
it's a different card that we need
oh hell okay fine whatever
we have everything here no we don't what
else is that again I'm not too sure how
to open that up buddy
leave that there oh hi teddy bear
there's a green hair about that see it
tempting me you know what I probably
could have done with all that extra ammo
well he has so many things a shoe wow
look at all this get some dinner here
dinner is served as like some mushy peas
perhaps
oh my god his head is my mouth she very
scared today I don't know why I feel
it's a lot better
how do we get him into the middle bit
cuz there's a lot of stuff to collect
that sins in the middle mashenka
[ __ ] shunka me which never works but
you know gets you angry
it might my damned into a little bit I
think I mean you would expect so
hopefully okay get off me
no thanks
music is making me test his idea
i'ma save room this is nice but like it
was going on forever with our save room
then okay this is a one of the nurses
journals admitted over 20 mystery
illness patients patients in the
isolation wing exhibiting severe limit
necrosis fever
muttering delirium and signs of hyper
for possible infection tried every
antiseptic still no blood work back from
the research ring asked again dr. Yan
was bitten while treating one of the
patients we've disinfected the wound but
his fever will go down nothing works
meanwhile the outpatient ring is
complete anarchy the patients are
delirious and growing more violent by
the minute we've called in an off-duty
staff it's all hands on deck now we've
got to contain this chaos yeah they
tried I appreciate you trying
no I don't want to examine and you
combined
one of you guys in here let me take this
out
yeah we don't need grads ID cards means
get a new one I guess for that door
I guess because this one only worked for
the police stations now we need to we
need to look for a new one
now Ulsan crops is like now might be a
good time to craft some hours if you've
got any feathers and stick also I
clipped some chickens for health what
gave me you referring to
twin doors I don't feed the troll okay
[Music]
save the gaming continue trying to save
this dude
oh there's something on here is that a
map thank you I thought you already had
oh no I didn't I was just doing a base
of where I knew there are stuff to pick
up around here
I guess I've got a chance to go
everywhere like this is a staff room and
then I can get back here oh this is
bloody as
there's a whole load of them she think
they're all alive
no baby
I'm very surprised
are they gonna come back to life
Oh liquors think liquors were here Mikey
we tried I swear to God we did but
there's nothing else to be done the
chaos has completely be under control
victims are pouring in now dying and
spreading the infection faster than we
can reach them so we've given up trying
those of us who aren't infected have
barricaded ourselves in here we can hear
the cries for help outside the screaming
but none of us will go out there because
it would be the end of us
I can't believe we that we've abandoned
our patients it's the worst sin
imaginable for a nurse I can't stop
shaking but I want to live I want to
live we heard a helicopter flying
overhead and immediately started crying
and hugging each other thinking a rescue
team was on the way but then the sound
grew distant and were all left all we're
left with now as the moaning of the dead
and the silent screams in our hearts
were all about to lose our minds dr.
young Ariana Miranda Dakota I'm so sorry
I failed something's coming help
I think it was aleca
is that everything that was in this room
to pick up the music is very well done
its evoke a many emotions don't like it
[Music]
ID cards are not to be taken off
hospital grounds in personal lockers
before returning home today the Keith
the locker room has gone missing the
last person to have it may have dropped
it in the courtyard okay until it's a
coverage we will keep a spare key here
in the office please stop by
administration oh okay so I need to go
to the Courtyard and I'm sure in there
will be the lockers and that's where I
get my little key card okay let's get
out this creepy ass place thank you
okay not this way well that was back
towards the way that we just went wasn't
it oh [ __ ] no I hadn't looked around yet
I'm just gonna like have a little peek
peek but okay sure wherever
thank you very much okay so this is
where we can go
how the key
hello
also green should we combines those
we've got a lot of stuff now what's over
here
oh I don't think there was another
window we could jump out of I think we
have to jump out of the other window to
get whatever's over that side okay way
down scream agreen so what's the
difference between green red green and
green with red sauce um a medium amount
of health oh and that's maximum
ramaa
I don't like retracing my steps and I
don't like it when the game saves like
that oh you can't see it's will have my
head but it was just saving
please back up no triple green equals
red and green equals first aids-free oh
okay cool cool
that makes sense thanks someone out of
it but where did he go
I just saw him though
nice yes
so we have the key now but let's just
hold on one second to be ever go in this
door no II didn't oh I don't like this
one
oh so many rooms that we have annex for
Jen makes me feel nervous you're trying
to get in both doors it's gonna be
horrible I do
are you done at least
why are they not coming in
I think I know what happened to the
missing tape of dr. B his research
assistant took it one of my patients
will Abbott removed something from a
locker in the nurse's station and walked
towards the treatment room I'll try to
sneak in and look during the night shift
you just stay cool and keep doing your
job I don't get how important dr. B is
to the medical community the that kind
of harassment is not okay I promise I
won't let them destroy the evidence he's
a pig and an [ __ ] and we'll get his
day oh well see what's he been doing
you made it
welcome to the party you too so glad you
could join oh wait hold up I've seen
some real oh [ __ ] beautiful
oh really
go home oh my god really [ __ ] something
else I don't even know I'm not gonna
gender stereotype but you know whatever
you are you are persistent oh my god
I always click there and it just doesn't
seem to do anything like that's actually
a major fall I've never been able to do
it once like don't even give me the
option if I can't actually do it if I
can't actually do it then what the hell
am I doing wrong
okay I'm good
Oh [ __ ] out I'll just run past so
quickly to get more through you alright
alright
I feel like there's one next to me I
don't know this is always one next to me
go that's not okay [ __ ] sake there
will be soon
so twice all night
okay I'm done in here wait
so what room does she see then go
towards the treatment room oh okay but I
need to go and get I need to go and get
the ID card all right whatever I'm
leaving you
and that wasn't that
more assault rifle Emma yeah I feel like
there's something else down here that we
should probably get it's too many things
too much stuff I actually have a lot
here I mean once we use that key we can
chuck it out I'm guessing it's locked
should I now do it later we'll get rid
of this key first
quit this game and go play Final Fantasy
I was more like well I mean I've already
played playing offense before so of
course I was more excited for this one
but now I am gonna I think burrow off my
friend that was the plan but then social
isolation so I'm not sure maybe I'll ask
if they can like post it it was
something is that PlayStation only it's
like I still do a livestream through my
PlayStation it's just not gonna be as
good quality
all right I'm here give me my key card
discard this one yes
oh my god I just got a flash back to
back in the police station when we read
that note about something being in the
locker pretty sure when we were ally on
the actually happened to us she came out
of the locker and she just like this one
well the chances
game playing with my little soul thank
you I needed that that's all I wanted oh
it's really unnerving the scratching
what is it like a scratchy violin or
something oh well this they've stayed
dead that's that's a good thing I'm
happy about that
[ __ ] see
it's a leak here no it's not what the
hell is this oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god
I think that Jesus Christ
oh what a beauty
Hamilton oh I find you happy oh yeah I
don't have the code for that
[Music]
do-do-do-do-do-do hmm I don't want to
put something away I feel like this is
all oh I'll put this one away but I
think I actually will keep everything
else shall we oh wait shall we
sure save will say oh no I'm starting to
the toilet I was okay
oh right right hey yeah I've got the
smallest butter I go to the toilet all
the time it's very annoying why is this
music so intense
oh not this way
go should we jump out the window or
should we use nah
well I use the keycard was it in this
room what everybody's using this one no
we just went here what's wrong with me
as a nurse's station
well
oh yeah there's another door downstairs
we're gonna get hello Oh God
okay I really don't want to go in there
I really don't want to go in there are
we going in there don't want to I mean I
have a flash grenade Ana grenades
[Music]
I am not alone here rarity how many
headshots
really are you I hate you what I've just
like the six shot you better stay down
now
much more like it I do I've got to go in
the treatment room oh is this one isn't
it
don't get oh my god did they get both of
them ah yes yes thank you grenade you
made my life so much easier now we get
to hear the evidence I want to know what
this man has done allegedly the
reptilian ones are alpha hunters well I
just killed two alpha hunters with a
well-placed grenade and eggs screams but
we can forget about that leave is to add
one hell yeah oh there's more listen
Ameren here brownie
where
nice
can we listen
can i play it can I play it or maybe I
have to wait until I'm back there to
play it yeah probably
darn it and what I hear it now okay
we'll go all the way back
they are dead
we're getting any of these codes am i
it's not on the eye chart
I don't remember picking up anything
that I had a code on that
what level you play normal
I was like I'm hearing something
oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] let's [ __ ] this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] there's open the door okay
alright alright
why'd you have your [ __ ] knife out oh
I don't okay
oh my god how many gun shows is take it
oh thank god okay why can't he be like
nemesis and drop some nice stuff for us
where's the savory yeah okay I'll just
save
okay so question which window did I
already jump out of what window did I
jump out
it was on this fall wasn't it that you
jump out of windows
yeah I think I jumped out of this one
but I can also jump out of this one so
I'll jump out of this one
is there anything here
No I thought that'd be something for me
to pick up here Oh maybe it's from a
different floor then
okay
and one caution I'll wait till I get
attacked again and then ah there's
[ __ ] loads of them there now oh this
is gonna be annoying Oh Oh God
see it's just every [ __ ] time just
doesn't work every [ __ ] time
sit on any caution hello are you guys
okay you're just going to answer nobody
get up nobody get up
I've really need something for these
there's so many of them
I will go in here what's in here oh just
got steam message no one this is just me
on Steam what is this
thanks for all the ammo
I see wait
but lost items we've been inundated with
reports of lost items if you find
something is unclear who it belongs to
do not take a home please deposit it in
the nurse's station safe oh now we have
the code to the safe we have to go all
the way back to the now stations frickin
ridiculous nine three nine clockwise
three counterclockwise okay right guys
we're gonna go up there and just hope
that it's worth it wow I mean this room
was definitely worth it oh hell yeah but
it makes me think that something's gonna
come up that will not be enjoyable and I
still need the toilet I'm doing like the
toilet dance but it's okay well and now
we'll go back up was it nine clockwise
three counterclockwise right huh I hope
so you know what my memories likes
pretty bad nine clockwise three
counterclockwise okay nine clockwise
three count
which way is the mass then again 9
clockwise 3 and counterclockwise I'm
just cute keep saying that
yep
so clockwise that way one two three four
five six seven eight nine one two three
just like that cool okay well I can't
complain cannot complain about that did
it also hasn't United thank you
did you
okay let's go back dance Jill now
there's something over here they can't
get to
oh wait no we're doing this first okay
let's play the tape who do you think
you're talking to I'm goddamn Nathaniel
Bard
I'm the best biologist you'll ever meet
you bet and changing waste of a nursing
degree of course I have connections
higher up of course the military
consults with me on projects beyond your
comprehension so like we do with your
nosy questions you didn't read the
documents did you know just like you
asked good good if that's all you can go
back to wiping your patients ass that's
what they pay you for write and polish
my shoes that's not what they pay you
for you know a lot about polishing don't
you now [ __ ] off and don't say a word to
anyone
Wow Wow
my words exactly Carlos we're on the
same wavelength here can we get through
now I'm gonna try out my new
a lot of stuff that's good
is it you you're dead
taro Bart's dead he's been shot
I'm looking
me and my fantastic hair will find it
it's my pleasure to cordially invite you
to the banquet on September 10th at the
Central Hotel where we'll be exchanging
viewpoints on wrecking city's new
special medical zone smz attending will
be Mayor Michael Warren Chief of Police
Brian ions and other distinguished
members of our community the orient
restaurant the Central Hotel second fall
we would be honored as you join us Greg
testa Nate I'll be introducing the bill
for that new drug of yours and
mid-august bring the cash we've booked a
suite to the usual after-party you're a
brunette guy right I let irons name
oh there's the computer the only one on
fix it pretty easy for us oh wow oh good
I don't need to use these anymore at
least get some space back
Gregor testa the dude that wrote the
letter Greg I know you're watching the
news this virus is going to devour the
whole country the dead will wash over
capitol hill like a tidal waves
you're not safe however you've always
been a good friend to me so I'd like to
offer you a way out I have in my
possession one dose of a vaccine to the
virus the Holy Grail and it's not for my
family not for my ladies on the side
what a douche
no Greg I'm saving it for you I know
better than anyone that you're the
future of the United States but if you
want the goods Greg you have to go and
get me the hell out of here now without
umbrella finding out leaned on the
Pentagon for me I know you've got the
clouds see if someone can get a rescue
team in here without you BCS involvement
you scratch my back I scratch yours we
should sound pretty chaste at after the
parties we've been to how are we my
time's running out so basically he was
like oh because you're my good pal I've
got this cure for you now he just wants
to use it as a way out he's just
thinking about himself he doesn't care
about anyone
I hope and pray by making this recording
and bringing the truth to light if I
can't restore some small shred of Honor
to my name all of the food cities
release of a biological weapon known as
the tea box
my employer the umbrella corporation
engineered this virus and they were
ordered to my to you to develop a
vaccine which we did that keep samples
of this vaccine here on amethyst the
rest of it was stored underground those
sons-of-bitches of the board they want
to destroy it they don't want the world
so they're trying to erase all evidence
that the virus ever existed
wonderful I know they don't want me to
[Music]
and she trusted me anyway
yep Jules a smart girl I'm a manly man I
hit things when I'm angry guy
here it is give it to Jill Jill you're
gonna be okay
don't come back to my place be careful
[Music]
[ __ ] bucket bucket bucket bucket
bucket bucket bucket [ __ ] [ __ ] it snake
snake snake oh it is why are we seeing
this
Oh [ __ ] though I didn't I juice the
boat why am I using my knife what no
wait oh my god that's okay let me just
equip this one
come on I got you with a grenade too so
yeah there you go
I still have one grenade
I really don't like those things [ __ ]
difficult still some stuff here for me
to pick up
it's just that
yeah
let's go to the toilet hi I will do see
I'll just go to jail yeah it's a sign of
a good game right when you don't even
want to leave go and do your basic
necessities great I'm just wasting my
bullets
tonight and I can
it's another path but we love these the
hearts of Raccoon City is healthcare the
forefront of science
Spencer Memorial Hospital was
meticulously designed by the Spencer
foundation to serve as the backbone of
medic wait now you've already read this
we both want the country's largest
research wings where we conduct clinical
trials for new drugs that we they will
change the face of medicine
okay Jill I have I have the vaccine
she better work
[Music]
okay why did you have to enter like that
[Music]
that's only a day away there's still
people to see you think Uncle Sam gives
a [ __ ] [ __ ] here they come are you sick
ah no I don't I'm not leaving the same
room okay hold up I've got one grenade
right I'm gonna save and then go to the
toilet sir
Deborah something I need to do you say
yeah I'll be right back just just one
second
I
returned
they should make you 28 days later
wasn't evil that reminds you plate
though
oh wait game but they made a while back
to remember that outbreak present even
outbreak it was just like running and
running and running in loads of zombies
and zombies and zombies I found
extremely difficult when all those kids
if I had it on ps2 I think it was we
want pac-man remakes someday oh yeah
okay that's so we just saved the game
but do I need anything I fine I've got
two green herbs I'm managing my I might
put one in here for the dot that and
that as well
I've got grenade I've got to flash
grenades my God's good amount of ammo so
okay
I feel like I should use my flash
grenade first just to get everyone a bit
confused
better how do we do that
[ __ ] this
oh my god oh [ __ ] I was trying to get
Wyatt boys on the table oh sure sure
sure
it just not gonna go well like I can
tell I can tell you this right now guys
it's not gonna go well
oh my god like I can hear them they're
everywhere
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you I
should have taken out more more stuff
for from my me me body weight
let's top it done
no no no I need you all enough give me
some time to recover please guys I could
use a good eight and then I show you is
another one I use this one I did I get
confusion oh come on
oh [ __ ] I'm out of ammo Oh
[Music]
and you'd this need this a detonator
where where do I use it what do I do
with it what do I do
where do I use this
oh [ __ ]
what am i finding too much stuff going
on a con can come straight
oh my god too much [ __ ] is happening
right why do I put this [ __ ] die
[ __ ] stressed
why did I just do that
no but I don't even I can't even I hear
them everywhere
can't see anything no no no [ __ ] I hate
them all
I hate all of you where's the big
beastie one wears a big beefsteak oh my
god my my game keeps passing out
oh no oh my dad so annoying so annoying
everyone's like breathe you're not the
one playing it's hard so many more [ __ ]
it
yes making mom fall cribs I was very
happy at least I knew where everything
is now right so it's probably wise I'm
gonna take out a few more stuff things I
take out on a first date
go like that no no that I love that oh
okay
when I skip this wait I should have
listened to that because I'm still not
too sure what I'm doing
hack into the security system
but how do I do that beforehand
oh no no no wrong one I won't see put
this one on here
where are they
Kable what do I do with this it's gonna
find somewhere to put it
[ __ ] it
how do they get that off I don't even
know
oh you know what I think monster comes
from there my inventory spell still okay
now that you say
yeah I'm pretty sure monster comes from
them
Oh make that one steam on steam on C Mon
C Mon steam unstirred
[ __ ] here we go here we go here we go
here we go whoo yeah whoo yeah
Oh me loves me here you come been
waiting for ye my everyone shut the [ __ ]
up where did he go where did he go where
did he go [ __ ] I missed him belches
please thank you
[ __ ] sake sir you so use hurry
Oh for [ __ ] sake it's cuz like when he
comes out it's just like one truck mine
just like get mafia game out of it
that's my mind just like get him out of
it get him out of it no I want to I want
to get this
whoa that was cool did you see that I
just punch stuff I need to pee okay oh
my god I'm trying to reload and [ __ ] hey
can't [ __ ] free love oh my god
everyone's too much can't do this it's
not even a horror game anymore [ __ ]
adventure game not actually game I guess
it's the adventure - I want you to die
because you're pissing me off
Oh
grenades [ __ ] yes grenades okay go go go
go
damn it I get out of there you'll [ __ ]
get out of there get out get out get out
get out get out get out I don't even
know what happened then okay there's a
cutscene oh [ __ ] oh we got through the
[ __ ] door too much going on it's
actually annoying
right
I'm trying one more time this time I'll
go in and get the grenades like as soon
as possible and then if I die again
I'm leaving cuz this is just me I'm
getting stressed
okay
so what am I supposed to do with that
ball
where do I put that bomb
you know what be really helpful right
now jails mind gun that would be perfect
yeah so where do I put it
where do I put said explosive
hey guys got cooldown how many makes
them but I want to use it all the time
oh [ __ ]
why the [ __ ] is she's just going back
then
where do I put this steep for I'm
actually very confused about where to
put the seat for because I think it
could be pretty useful
okay
oh god I know what that was I know what
that noise was and yes I know what it is
come on just [ __ ] throw your [ __ ] yep
okay I'm doing no I'm not gonna say it
I'm not gonna say anything oh really
oh right so that's where you come from
cotton-eye Joe
make sure they don't get
okay okay oh [ __ ] I haven't killed you
yet I haven't killed yet get off my hair
nobody touches the hair my hair it's
glorious
you are not allowed such good look but
you can't touch there come on three
loads don't have any other well that's
just [ __ ] brilliant
right
oh my god get off of me
what I told you about my hair
Oh [ __ ] sake
how we feel in their only caution about
okay it's a cautionary tale I don't have
any ammo
alright I have [ __ ] don't I need to
get the [ __ ] out of here right go go go
I need to just check and see if ah thank
God right
Oh God
no it bounced off
where's it go Oh the funk scene
I need I need more ammo or something
absolutely offenders
I just gotta clean up yep I have no ammo
you just gonna have to sucker punch em
all
[Music]
good Oh Oh finally now I can [ __ ] use
it you kidding me
Oh get out of my [ __ ] way I need I
need
ah I'm actually getting so angry it's
not okay
this is just not okay he's just not
working
[Music]
and also you can't Knight them like when
they grab you like this you can't knife
them anymore and I miss them from
Resident Evil 2 why can't I just knife
them oh thank god
okay ah thank God close no yes I'm
coming back
thank God for these generators
it seems a real deal good.you dog
somewhere
you damn right what do you think you're
gonna do hope city's about to be
microwaved tell them we found a cure you
stall for time
thank you Father follows Ola Joshua and
Southwest and thank you for everyone
being nice and not telling me that I'm
being stupid some of you are it's hard
you start panicking there's so many
to
good news it's over now
Missy see
it's a dream no it's not oh thank God it
was a dream we're okay
I knew this dream going on where are
they then
attention all citizens the missile
strike
yeah you've been up for a while
okay guys what the hell where have they
gone
what did we miss we got some oh I shall
take out one of these should take out
two we got explosive rounds as well
oh I want to find another pouch for her
this isn't enough stuff I don't feel
safe okay
I guess it's a hot point now isn't it
one bullet what was the prey in that I'm
just gonna stop
okay
the hair was still on fleek though thank
you after being um I don't want to say
the word have to be like devoured a
couple of times Carlos's hair was still
looking fine sunshine
oh [ __ ] didn't those all Carlos he
carried you here he treated you himself
crazy bastard where is he
Bard's stockpile the vaccine enough to
give it a city some hope he thinks he
can do this point myself I'm going after
him
wait did you see the broadcast they're
gonna blow the city sky-high
I'm trying to get a hold of someone
anyone with the parents to stop it he
was nice to him he's professional so am
I knew it
cool it babe guess I'm not talking you
out of this snake storage facilities I
can't believe Carlos took the pouch and
didn't leave it patil what a selfish
prick
thanks for clearing this all up Carlos
really appreciate it you did a good job
I have the lock pick time oh yeah
knew I'd come back here's Jill so do I
use it on these ones yes
wait
well
I don't even have that gun okay so I'm
gonna get a new guns
I've gotta find a way to get out there I
guess maybe Jill can if I couldn't as
Carlos
and keep my wits about me
hmm Oh unless I can I can come back this
way and then go out this way
which way do I go let me go around but
there's something in here that I need to
get early
although I don't think I have any pocket
space just looks like you Nikolai's work
yes we have seen him kill his own men so
I wouldn't put it past him okay
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] don't you [ __ ] oh I love oh [ __ ]
I love the shotgun so much
so I've got I'll save them my wine round
and have flame rounds explosive rounds
as well
as more explosive rounds I think than
anything
and here
yeah oh wait hold up if I change to
something else
Wow I can only get six
okay I'll come back
okay so how do we get out to the
courtyard that ways blocks go this way
hmm yeah I still can't jump over the of
the hedge or anything there's got to be
another window above so I can jump out
of
he's still hey I didn't see you here
before
did you just appear for me I feel
privileged Oh greeted by a big monster
eh okay let's go to the save room and
took some stuff ready
oh why man here well frankly did some
stuff I can get
ah should saved this
okay well I know it's here
let's go - lets go - drop stuff off
where is it
in the linen bring this something as
well right but yes we we don't have any
consistently myself we're gonna put
stuff away first by Counting which room
is in right other
Liz why
beautiful throw mine mounds they're very
dear to us so that one yeah we must be
having a new gun soon then
okay let's get to me means to get some
more shotgun because I love my shotgun I
don't like the pup I don't have any ammo
for it right now let's get back and get
this stuff
if we find normal gunpowder and we can
mix it with this one and then we can
have some of shotgun shells at least
oh yeah how about this
I'm so glad that I've cleared everything
up
[Music]
it is oh yeah this
please study if only there was a
donation button see I can get bigger
pockets yes Joel needs more pooches
oh the pooches gunman
ah
didn't do that last time went the long
way back
something in here for me apparently
apparently but Wow cuz it's red so
should be something here
ah
okay I'm just gonna go soil my inventory
apologies this might be a bit of a
boring part but you know you gotta do
what I gotta do make sure I'm Foley's
repairs okay so yeah we can stall this
one take this one out combine these oh I
guess I could do that on the day with
that one kind of wish we had a gunpowder
now but I guess we'll store this for now
oh we do have two more shells you have
two more shells without that bad and
yeah it should be fun about the health
situation we've got one or should we
take this one as well and I'm sure okay
and then we'll go squeeze through the
little thing
I'm guessing where we squeeze through
that's gonna be where we can jump down
to the new place as well
go on in jail
yeah they guess there's the broken glass
Oh stuff body bag
here you are I didn't keep any of your
balance
my
[Music]
we're now
oh my god there's stuff in the sickroom
that I didn't pick up one easiest
I'll come back this way okay this one is
Wow
it
oh my god when we get in the hallway
what's this way and then this way
oh my god sorry I'm doing already stupid
I was going the right way okay
I thought I was back in the corridor Bay
again oh I am but no I guess okay it's
the right way this mean thing
oh my god I was not expecting anything
back here
let's run right into him oh I just went
right past all of this stuff
oh okay cool so all of that was just
kind of lit up I guess pick up
everything we left here what we've got
so many guns what the hell which gun
should we keep which should we get rid
of because we can't keep these all of
these guns
I mean Oh too many
the Magnum seems pretty good the
Lightning Hawk lightning hog I like my
shotgun though you guys know I like my
shotgun
and you can put this back I don't care
about that one
[Music]
we really need more pockets don't we
badly
okay
that's a lot of guns I feel like I
should put one extra one away but I
don't know which I can't choose
you guys are saying good choice Thanks
I'll take that's one
this must be the way around
umbrella bagels
this is stuff to pick up around here
though I don't want to trigger a
cutscene without finding it oh here we
go
yeah
I like that that you can just quickly
check them up and see if there's
something in the room on up
by
was that no one in the hospital
well they probably did but they kept it
under wraps and they wouldn't let the
people who would tell no about it
thank you
well you guys from my sandwiches
did she take a knife this time so Jill
doesn't have a knife
oh look at that I just wants to say I
might stop playing but we just found a
pooch I'm gonna stop playing soon though
oh crap
summertime usually only seems like two
hours what's happening wow it means what
I'm enjoying myself so that's good um
well we'll just have a little look
around and then I'll probably leave to
all employees we've identified an issue
with the electrical box where concurrent
use of heavy machinery over light loads
it and causes the fuse to blow if you
encounter this problem and can't get the
elevator running please stay calm gals
fuses from the sub generators situated
around the warehouse and use those to
restore power from the main generator
okay
I never use this why do I never use this
right
oh no there was a knife I lied but there
was not never enough pocket space and
now there is kind of is there I still
don't think there is right stall this
one get this one now that's better
I think Broadus keep like thanks and
they've got three free ones which is
quite good
we're in quarantine why stop cuz I cows
sleep still and these are headphones I
ready to get some better ones because
they hurt my look who it is
you see him I keep just getting
distracted
there he is Nikolai right that's Nikolai
but yeah my my headphones really hurt my
ears if I wear them for longer than like
two hours so my ears are hurting right
now shooter I talked to Nick lie I think
you're on my side levees leavers
hey Beach I see you Chelsea
didn't even flinch what a man is insane
that's really a very intriguing
conversation hey zombie probably gonna
fall down on you
combined with explosive a to make
flaming rounds or B to make acid sounds
we already have acid rounds maybe notice
wait I might just wait
hey you look at me just did that
where's like a
feel that there's so many options that
in order to choose are you gonna fall if
I come down here you're gonna fall no
okay
oh I thought that green barrel thing was
a something okay
I knew you were gonna fall you you are
you us something else you Brady are
sponsons
oh my god
Wow okay you were like super zombie and
I didn't realize
how many shots does it take to kill yay
is he putting me doing this oh my god oh
my god oh my god okay I think I'm gonna
have to switch out to a bus again
oh thank god
yeah that one was a praetor it was very
surprising I didn't I thought it'd just
be like a normal zombie but just a bit
more charred
Oh Nicky oh I think only Carlos does the
punches in this game I've never seen her
do a punch before when she does this so
that's why I was pretty Wow what he did
it because I've never seen ever but if
anyone knows in the chat then do let me
know if I'm talking crap
okay so I've got one fuse what there was
already a fuse in there so I think
actually I just need to get one more
fuse
what the hell just happened
dogs whoa so cool I can't see gonna
preserve my shotgun I just feel like
that they're good for dogs because
they're like a wider range at close up
and dogs like to get in your feet I
don't know why I'm justifying my weapon
choice to you guys right um no more dogs
please no more dos can do this
stay in there like um well I guess yes I
am trying to stay alive urine urine
normal zombie I think use my normal gun
on you - [ __ ] sake
if I can just age correctly
it wasn't as something like that oh yeah
oh maybe now
okay watch out you might be dogs or
something
so one this
don't trust anything
what's this
ooh thanks I just want some more shotgun
shells now please
am I missing anything over here
so much fun getting away
you know mother leave yet you know [ __ ]
another one behind you though not the
one behind you though
Oh God
[Music]
okay
set shotgun shells
how the [ __ ] ah thank God
hello hmm I've got shotgun shells in
here all along I think cuz it's only two
and once I just put them in there okay
okay so we just need to find what one
more fuse
[Music]
I'm out of water
I can't bother to get up though
apparently I'm almost at the end but
Nikki says save and call it a day maybe
let me just get this last fuse I can
make more shotgun shells I might die in
a second anyway because this music is a
little bit unnerving oh hell yeah but go
there maybe not we got it we got the
other for you
is that all that's down here
it's a lot of red
oh wow
all righty I'm about one half two hours
away which of death so it definitely
will be the next stream probably that I
finish the game okay what we can do so
you've got this one you can make some
perfect
it's really really nice
and that's it we just need yeah I just
need those two
I'm just gonna put it in and go up the
escalator and then gas ask elevator and
I guess it will start cutscene and then
I'll probably call it a day
you're okay Jill that's all this lifts
leave a little Eva mmm it's annoying
that it's still red
oh no there's another one that we have
to get oh and it looks like you have to
put them in maybe a certain order I'm
not sure
hmm you I wonder where that one is then
let's go around again trying to find it
where could you be
Nikki's like a Levesque you later yeah
let's call it an LMS collator kind of an
elevator escalator elevation platform
okay so we got one from here won't even
in here
this is where the dogs were
which was not fun
we didn't go up here
looks like the control for this a
Levesque alator is elsewhere
was it how
hmm
can't do it that way
oh I can hear a popping head where is he
there is
the hell
ah can I go here
this is the control for this L of
escalator
but no fuse
ah laterally
excuse me heard some weird noises I
don't like those noises
okay sis you
oh my god
how am I supposed to compete with that
what how am I supposed to compete with
them I just look at become as I see
leave is like it's fine
[Music]
right I think I will leave that one for
next time oh I do have that gun Oh Oscar
I'll try no I don't want to go into
assisted mode game so ruler sister I
don't need to go on assisted mode I am
okay I got this um yeah I'll just get
out my explosive gun I guess
yeah okay my explosive gun that's gonna
help me a lot in that situation
wait why did I do that Oh [ __ ] sake oh
that's actually really annoying
oh well let's go around the long way
yeah yes because I love this level
design so much Thanks
yeah hey it makes the stream a little
bit longer
what Lowell mgs vs. chicken hat I'm so
confused
okay down here and then
this way
[Music]
yeah I think I should have this now that
I know what to expect you're right
Oh
first thing this would help
okay so I got zombies to my right and
the gobbly one stir to my left so pretty
obvious which one I should take out
first really isn't it I wish I could
quick save and just save at the top of
that ladder
okay you got those explosive rounds do
you have enough five of these
open up your cup open up your gob do it
quickly please I want to kill you now
oh my god so much so you're so much
going on so much death so much happening
so much happening can't do this I'm
rolling around
I'm brought around from Sonic I'm Sonic
Sonic the Hedgehog [ __ ] am i dying again
[Music]
one more time I'm not gonna get I don't
have to go around the long way right I
think you left I think I was just stupid
last time I went round the wrong I
should really just heal myself now as
well okay right healing myself putting
this one in here I'll cow this one just
in case I need
oh you kidding me I do have to go all
that way around
oh wait wait wait no I don't like to go
this way get something I didn't see
employee memo discarded me oh oh oh this
is like admitted and discarded oh
they've returned some unexpected female
oh wait she was eight years old it
wasn't how many there were
oh they preemptively start dispersing
any over the age of 30 oh that's when
they the nurse all that nightly transfer
and then they stopped so this was the
kind of like hidden door that she saw
them putting the bodies from the
hospital into shady stuff
okay so again flaming rounds
Oh
I'm sure we use explosives you only got
three explosive okay it's just hopeless
oh good the root dad thank God
oh god nobody gotta go
I'm glad he waited from me with his
mouth open like that thank you sir
means a lot I was she died now
okay that was not easier
I forgot that they take two hits today I
thought they only took one sure thing I
can combine make some more shotgun
shells ah that's nice
some guessing the fuse must be in his
carriage where was it
what kidding me
don't miss it did I pick it up 40 no
where is it then
they've been happening pocket space now
anyway
oh here it is what I still not have
enough pockets bees don't know do I do
just oh so annoying okay well you guys
entertain yourself so I'm gonna go put
something in my storage and then come
back and get the fuse because I am
tempted to drop the green half at the
same time I know that I need all the
green herbs I can possibly get so I am
NOT dropping it
you're also just starting to drop the
green herb nah I am NOT I need every
green herb I can possibly keep
perfect
now I've got them all
okay let's trigger off this cutscene and
then I'll call it a night it's pretty
good stream though isn't it time flies
when you're killing zombies and getting
angry I know you guys get to see so many
different sides of me
it's no joke I'll be like all happy and
smiley one minute okay
let's go do this I'm safe
oh hello big boys oh [ __ ] I was just I
was just switching up a weapon
see Jesus
yeah I want to get it back together me
that when you go on my hand like these
did you not learn
oh there's a little girl down the radio
but see this is why I was so reluctant
to get rid of that herb you see you see
how much I need it ah thank you shotgun
you are my best friend
[Music]
ah here we go let's go up
of course he did he's on the phone no I
don't you may examine it
nothing else okay this is where I'm
calling it guys I think next time oh
we're out of ammo for that one but we
can make some more gassy
and we're on caution house but that
should be okay so I wait till next time
[Music]
anyway I I'm just like leaving back
reading their comments I had a good
stream tonight I hope you guys enjoyed
it I'm looking forward to playing more
of this game for you it looks like we're
nailed the end so next stream might be
the last stream of Resident Evil perhaps
maybe we shall see
but either way thanks very much for
being with me tonight and enjoying the
live stream make sure you follow me on
Twitter and I'll give you a link for the
discord it is in the description down
below as well if you want to become a
part of our little discord community
we've got going on it's very nice
community we chat a lot you guys chat a
lot we have lots of different channels
about all of our creative topics that we
we like to talk about really and I let
you guys know when I'm working on
something new when to expect new videos
when to expect new live streams but also
I do the same on like Twitter anyway so